n'oubliez pas les personnes âgées cette
année cette année en europe en effet
c'est l'année des personnes âgées
alors voici une jolie opération en tout
cas elle s'appelle poésie à tous les
étages
elle est organisée par l'association la
flamboyance les jeunes vont porter des
poèmes à ceux qui pourraient être leurs
grands parents
reportage dans le 20e arrondissement de
paris patrick rex club michel jane latos
la poésie nouvelle est arrivée mais les
valeurs sûres sont encore au goût du
jour
brassens sonné balade rondeau à
l'honneur les grands messes victor hugo
prévert mais également les poètes en
herbe qui n'ont pas hésité à glaner des
rimes accueillir des mots en classe
l'occasion d'offrir un bouquet de
tendresse au troisième âge exercice très
apprécié même si les méthodes sont
différentes nous la faisons faisait
apprendre par coeur
avec le temps file et gestes c'est
peut-être une bonne méthode quand même
pour la feuille je répondis c'est du
veau il colle à l'énorme 0 mais je
pensais in petto t'en fais pas beaucoup
leurs portes comme une boule ne te mets
pas les nerfs en boule les tracas ça
rend ma boule alors tu le récit fait que
font ceux des poèmes si l'on réussit
depuis qu'on apprenne et puis un plan
qui comme ça quand il était jeune
ainsi pour ma maman le courant est passé
deux heures de poésie non-stop
les papys et mamies
en demandent encore ce n'est jamais pour
de la rambarde horn assez monsieur pas
d'estimation je ne souffrirai point
d'interrogation du traitement certains
étaient prêts philosophe né sous le coup
d'une telle apostrophes et comprenant le
fou de sa situation il renonça soudain à
toute l'union